now there's yet another reason for
visitors to flock to the Palace of
Versailles already one of France's
biggest tourist attractions the new
water theatre Grove is located some 400
metres north of the palace it adds a
dash of modern art to the traditional
gardens yes we'll see Rosa Milich rescue
of course it's daring but creativity is
always staring sekulic at Versailles
people see what was created before and
what's being created today without
betraying its history the new fountain
and surroundings are the work of
landscape architect Louie benesh and
glass artist Jean Michelle Oh Tanya in
2011 they were the winners of a
competition beating out 26 other
submissions is fckd campus important I
wanted to work with someone whose
creations reminded me of childhood whose
art appeals to everyone I found jamesha
Latonia and I'm very happy with my
choice yeah yeah place your northern up
it's impressive to get the chance to
create a work for the Palace of
Versailles that will always remain there
it's not like a short-term exhibition
where you can indulge in extravagances
lon Fessler metaphysics have a ghost pls
ff10 awesome this contemporary creation
is a first for Versailles because it
will remain here permanently until now
contemporary artists like Jeff Koons and
joana vasconcelos have exhibited their
works at the palace but only temporarily
by music usually don't ownership the
palace isn't a museum in which time has
Stood Still even during the time of
Louie the fourteenth verse I was a
creative place I feel it's our duty to
welcome artists as long as their works
are in keeping with the palace
jean-michel found inspiration for his
new creation in louis the 14th himself
during his research he discovered the
Sun King sketches of his garden and his
love of dance the three water sculptures
represent three different dances the
opening was also inaugurated with the
dance performed by the renowned la dance
project Shiho did see me I transform the
early baroque dances into sculptures
when you see them you'll recognize my
personal style but it also makes you
think of the Sun King always on probably
when Bonnie could do what Louis the
fourteenth was a king who like to
combine various art forms then he was
fond of dancing he made don't see 300
years ago he danced here himself was his
own the project took four years to
complete when once it up on your frogs
I've never worked this long on a project
the 2,000 glass beads were blown in
Switzerland the four blue ones in Murano
Italy 22,000 sheets of gold leaf went
into the beads then there was the
technical system the pumps and cables it
was incredible work but worth it the
movie palace of MODOK the Grove covers
an area of one-and-a-half hectares
though much of the foliage is invisible
yet as the plants still need time to
grow
so what's the LA you can't see it yet
but the treetops will grow together and
form a circle light will come from the
ground in the water but the rest will be
quite dark because they're evergreens a
garden grows slower than a person but
it's similar a person is mature at 40 in
30 years this garden will look like
something for now there are no plans for
similar projects here whether you're a
lover of historical architecture or
prefer contemporary artworks there's
something for everyone at Versailles